hallo leute ich ist wieder eure mal
wanne und willkommen zu einer neuen
folge heute habe ich was ganz besonderes
für euch wir machen unseren eigenen
trickfilm mit knete alles klar wir haben
knete hintergründe einmal ein raumschiff
und einen friedhof
ich bin guter werwolf ich glaube ich
nehme den friedhof war halloween vor der
tür steht
was für ein realistischer hintergrund
ich bin auf einem friedhof veranstaltung
schaumstoff wo man dinge haus blocken
das ist wie dieses puzzle spiel für
kinder immer so sachen durch decken muss
ich bin schlecht so lange kennt man
will's wissen gemacht ich bin aufgeregt
werkzeug einen boden
dafür brauche ich keine anleitung ich
weiß schon wie das kredit jetzt tut man
das also rein
na ja und wir haben einmal so augen
schifflinger bilder kann man auch so
ausklappen und so grabsteine und einmal
so augen und damit kameras an freunde
wir machen es nach den guten alten stop
motion trägt dafür brauche ich noch eine
kamera und ein stativ sieht man aus wie
eine spinne reitet entente die auf mit
tesafilm festmachen
ich soll jetzt jedes ding da unten mit
tesafilm zu machen
nichts leichter als das sagte frederik
warum ist er so etwas wie recht
wahrscheinlich mache es ganz kurz fertig
und jetzt die gleiches ergebnis also
jetzt kann da ein gruseliger hintergrund
jetzt müssen wir die kamera aufstellen
unser bühne ist aufgebaut
für den aufbau gebe ich schon halb fünf
kommen wir nun endlich zum spaßigen teil
verkneten komisch gut was kneten wir
denn es ist halloween
das ist ein kürbis machen einen
gruseligen kürbis nicht weiß es ist
jetzt nicht so spektakulär aber ja na
super jetzt immer schon monat puzzeln
drei körpers ist rund und gesund
ich sehe dass ich noch moos ab das macht
die ganze sache noch gruseliger dass
mein friedhof drauf ich mich überaus
freuen kann
skalpell oder machen kenia ist jedoch
gerade mit knete arbeiten eine freundin
von mir die snap i hat einen kanal auf
gemacht indem sie viel auch mit fimo
bastelt und so allgemein so sachen macht
indem es den harry potter zauberstab
gemacht ihr könnt ihr mal vorbeischauen
ich verlinke euch den kanal und nhl
schlechter aus
ja man das sieht aus wie kürbis voll
stolz auf mich hier vor die technik
angewendet
jamann
ich mache mir ich mache mir so eine
animation mal seine entführen oktober ja
darüber kann man sich auch mehr oder
weniger freuen
guck mal das ist ein rückschritt ist ein
kleiner kürbis okay jetzt braucht der
fremdkörper es nur meister augen machen
einen kiffen nennen also rote augen und
einen mund kriegt er somit getestet und
aber wie kommt denn jetzt so ein kürbis
ins bild dass ihr rollen okay ich da
einfach mal rein
dass sie für kaka aus olja der kommt mit
irgendwas angefahren habe ich ein auto
haben auch ihr sohn stars scheiß erich
may natürlich wäre es cool ist davos
zeigt das einzige modell auto was ich
gefunden habe ist das habe ich mir vor
jahren von einer freundin geschickt um
meiner besten freundin ann christin
hallo angriffe postel aber ist viel zu
groß sein oder ich zeige euch das mal
wie das gut aussieht warum brauchen wir
es doch motion wenn wir das hier haben
idee nummer zwei auf dem arsch von einem
esel wie macht man einen esel gruselig
guck mal wie crew sich das aussieht wenn
man die knochen darauf macht wo einheit
knochen beine ruhig bin ein gruseliger
esel jetzt nur mal so als spoiler für
evtl
da kommt so reingeritten ohne werk wo
der kö gesagt gebt euren daumen nach
oben und dann sagt der esel und
abonniert den kanal kürbis sieht jetzt
aus wie harry potter jetzt kriegt ja
noch eine kleine narbe und einen
zauberstab und dann ist es harry potter
harry kürbis potter habt ihr die
verstanden was mache ich den zauberstab
aus einem zahnstocher jetzt so harry
potter zauberstab bereit für den
klassischen animationsfilme aller zeiten
ja dann film ab
wir hoffen euch hat das video gefallen
wenn ja dann abonniert doch den kanal
bis dann
nun gibt uns euren abgetrennten daumen
nach oben und so leicht macht man seinen
eigenen animationsfilm dafür braucht ihr
nur ein bisschen knete einen zahnstocher
und so ein bisschen scheiße
wir sind uns beim nächsten video wieder
biss dann